our senior level leaders what do they do
they're all those people are still in
those positions if they've retired
they're going there on the board at
raytheon or general dynamics or
something like that so when we look at
lobbyists and politicians and uh think
tanks and that military industrial
complex that's a that's a real thing
that's an animal and uh and when when
it's not in hell to check and no one's
held accountable you get things like the
disastrous withdrawal from afghanistan
essentially rushing to our death after
20 years of being able to prepare and
plan for that eventuality it's uh it's
inexcusable
what do you make of the state of the
military at the moment and the state of
the way that it seems
politics has really infected the
military at least in the last say five
ten ten years that it didn't seem it did
before maybe we didn't know about it
before
yeah so uh obviously politics has been
creeping into all aspects of our culture
for a long time uh people like to point
to hollywood but hey look at there's
wall street more and more into sports i
mean almost every education of course um
literally every aspect of society we
thought the military was immune from
that and we found out over the last
couple years that it is most certainly
not um and really not even talking about
that the wokeness in the military or
anything like that we can just go and
look at 20 years of our experience in
iraq and afghanistan and how none of our
senior military leaders have been held
accountable for the decisions that they
made and we can go back and look at each
and every one of these guys the stars on
their shoulders sitting in front of
congress saying the exact same things
year after year you can take the year
off there and it's a different person
but the audio will be exactly the same
meeting our milestones the the afghan
national army is getting closer to being
able to stand up on their own we just
need more resources more people more
funding
more equipment whatever it is and uh
then the afghanistan papers was
published and i hope more people read
the afghanistan papers by craig whitlock
because what he does is takes these
interviews that the senior level leaders
thought were going to remain classified
juxtaposes it with what they're saying
in front of congress so to the america
to congress to their troops and
essentially you have two separate
stories 180 out from one another uh and
so they are essentially lying to their
troops lying to congress lying to the
american people and these senior level
leaders continue to fail up and we see
what happens when we continue to do that
year after year and hold no senior level
leaders accountable we have a withdrawal
from afghanistan that looks like what we
saw last august which the media of
course doesn't even talk about anymore
but we all got to watch with our own
eyes and it's also why everyone in this
country with a little bit of common
sense
could could comment on it because you
didn't need to have a touch point with
the military or study strategy or
tactics or military history at all you
could just look at that and apply some
common sense which is something that
carl von klauschwitz said was the most
important aspect of any military leader
any combat leader is having common sense
and so anyone could look at that and say
why are we giving up this tactically
advantageous position at bagram and
putting america's sons and daughters in
a tactically disadvantageous position
when we've had 20 years to prepare for
this eventuality and this is the best
the united states military can do this
is the best that that we have this is
what we're giving our are giving our
sons and daughters is we're putting them
in this position now if you've done that
at the tactical level as an old three so
as a captain in the army or a lieutenant
in the navy or something like that or as
a chief in the navy or something a
sergeant you would be court-martialed
sent home if you just
are senior level leaders what do they do
they all those people are still in those
positions if they've retired they're
going they're on the board at raytheon
or general dynamics or something like
that so when we look at lobbyists and
politicians and uh think tanks and that
military industrial complex that's a
that's a real thing that's an animal and
uh and when when it's not held to check
and no one's held accountable you get
things like the disastrous withdrawal
from afghanistan essentially rushing to
our death after 20 years of being able
to prepare and plan for that eventuality
it's uh it's inexcusable so i don't know
if you know this about me but every
august i take i go off the grid for a
month no phone no news
no communication with the outside world
i literally disappear for a month so the
the august uh this past august obviously
was the afghanistan withdrawal so i did
not know that until september 1st i come
back and i have a guest host it was adam
carolla this past year who kind of
caught me up to speed on everything so i
was seeing all those videos you know two
weeks later all in real time for the
first time in front of my audience and
what i said to adam watching them in
real time was this from what i could
tell just seeing it all right in front
of me right at that moment all at once
that this could not have been worse that
if you had intentionally tried to bungle
something at the highest level that
that's pretty much what it would have
looked like
do you think that's a fair estimation 20
years from now when we look back on this
thing what do you think the post-mortem
is going to look like
well if it's honest it's going to be
exactly what you what you just said
right there you could not have have
bungled this worse had you actually been
trying um and once again it's that
accountability piece but you know what
we had we had 20 years of our own
experience to look back on to to take
lessons from to apply going forward as
wisdom we didn't even have to go back to
the soviets i mean we should have
earlier on gone back to 79 to 89 the
soviet experience in afghanistan we
didn't have to go back to the three
british incursions in the 1800s early
1900s certainly didn't have to go back
to alexander the great genghis khan
although he could happen we could have
taken lessons from all of those things
and applied them to our present
situation as wisdom yet we did not we
think of things in terms of four year
election cycles eight year election
cycles for the real deep thinkers among
us um but we what we neglect to do is go
back in the pages of history take those
lessons and apply them going forward and
uh that's obviously the detriment of our
sons and daughters who are out there on
the front line and we saw in afghanistan
13 lost their lives to say nothing of
those who lost arms and legs and can't
walk anymore
or dealing with the post-traumatic
stress or traumatic brain injury from
from a position that they were put in by
our senior level leaders is it crazy to
you how quickly we just move off things
like that i mean as you said it was the
longest war in american history we were
there for 20 years it was very unclear
to a lot of people sort of why we were
there and how it was connected to 911
and all of that stuff but that basically
uh we had two or three weeks of sort of
news cycle and outrage and now it's it's
completely not talked about and you know
we've got this situation in ukraine
right now and it's like do our allies
trust us does anyone believe what we're
doing do we have the right people in
charge any of that
yeah no it's uh those are valid valid
questions and uh as it pertains to
what's going on in afghanistan vis-a-vis
or in uh in ukraine visiting russia uh
once again we had a lot of data in which
to look at and predict what was going to
happen in my second novel true believer
i actually use a false flag operation it
came out in 2019 but i used a false flag
operation to uh to instigate a russian
invasion of ukraine um and uh i got that
just by studying the situation at the
time so i was writing that in uh
2016 2017 um editing it in 2018 so it
could come out in 2019 but uh that
research should have shown anybody that
hey this is essentially inevitable
because the uh the russian population uh
is in a steep decline it has been since
the end of the cold war and they are
very a couple generations away from
there being no ethnic russians and
they're certainly very close to not
being able to field an army in the
numbers that they have
have been able to in the past uh and at
the time it was about 2022. uh there's
actually a book uh called the accidental
superpower while peter peter zeon who
looks at geography and demographics as
far as world history and superpowers and
how that has has played in and uh yeah
2022 was about the last year that uh
russia had before they would not be able
to field an army capable of invading
ukraine because they need those ethnic
russians and ukraine has the largest
population of ethnic russians in the
world outside of russia
so these things were predictable um and
then of course we can go back to world
war one world war ii end of the cold war
promises made we rarely put ourselves in
our enemy's shoes and uh red game things
from that position um red cell things
from that position but uh we should do
that more often because we make wiser
decisions
what do you think the role of the
american military should be at this
point it seems like it really has
sort of changed or it seemed like it was
changing at least you know under trump
there basically there was a lot of peace
there was a lot of like oh if we mess
with this guy we don't know what he's
going to do you remember he dropped that
that mother of all bombs in iraq nobody
understood why and it was like well it
got pretty quiet there pretty quick uh
and now we we're in this ukraine
situation what do you think the general
role of america
worldwide should be
well it it should be one of respect and
fear that goes along with that um
because that that military is really
what backs like the second amendment to
the first amendment um the military it
backs up everything that we say and that
we do uh so if we have this
strong military that is more concerned
with other people's borders rather than
than our own
well essentially we're seeing an
invasion across our southern border
right now that's once again not really
talked about in in the mainstream press
uh it's been going for for quite some
time but uh we have all sorts of issues
like that and if uh and we have a
department of defense after world war
two it used to be the department of war
uh the war department then it changed uh
1947 and really since then we haven't
done very well uh in in conflicts and
that's the exact same time that
accountability shifted and by shifted i
mean that we started not holding our
senior level leaders accountable uh when
we talk about george marshall he's most
known for the marshall plan after world
war ii but really what's more important
is what he did in their lead up to world
war ii and during world war ii which
were fire those leaders who didn't cut
it so he put all those guys in positions
whose names we know today as leading us
through that led us through world war ii
to victory um but had he not done that
and just let those people who are in
those places that weren't cutting it i
mean who knows how world war ii would
have turned out but he fired people that
didn't cut it after world war ii and we
shift over to the department of defense
things start to change korea vietnam and
obviously what we see today and we for
whatever reason we're hesitant to hold
these senior level leaders accountable
but we can trace it all the way back to
the end of world war ii and uh in 1947
but um yeah today it's uh we're in an
interesting position and uh in that yes
we have a technological we have 20 years
of experience and we have this
technology that has just been racing
forward when it comes to uh it comes to
our weapon systems and so we take those
tactical lessons learned take these new
weapons and uh and the technology as far
as tracking and targeting and all the
rest of it we should have the most
feared military on the planet yet we
have a border that's just
porous essentially and we're we see what
we saw in afghanistan so with all that
technology all those lessons we still
get that outcome in afghanistan so if
i'm the enemy and i'm looking at that
that gives me some wiggle room and that
gives me some lessons learned to apply
to my future battle plans that probably
go more than four to eight years in
advance i can think decades i can think
even centuries if i'm china and i can
apply these lessons to uh to that those
battle plans if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell